just a few hundred kilometers south
east from here the world's largest
automotive supplier bosch
is opening a new semiconductor plant in
dresden today
bosch has invested 1 billion euros in
the site
which will focus on the production of
microchips for the car
industry the auto sector depends heavily
on
semiconductors from asia but disruptions
in the global supply chain during the
coronavirus pandemic
have led to massive shortages the plant
is europe's first fully digitized and
highly networked semiconductor factory
the german government also invested in
the plant start of production is slated
for july
2021.
for physicist jochen rinderkinisch
quality control is up next
when it comes to chips it's all about
the tiny details
a single chip no larger than a
fingernail contains several billion
transistors
the science behind it is amazing
we can check individual transistors if
we suspect there's a defect
we can find a specific transistor among
five billion of them cut it analyze it
closely
and find the cause of the defect tens of
thousands of silicon wafers packed in
boxes are moving through the production
sites of global foundries
europe's largest chip producer 24 hours
a day
seven days a week
once ordered it can take up to three
months to produce a chip
some of the factory machinery costs as
much as an aircraft
we see sustained high customer demand
the plant is already fully booked this
year and to a large extent next year
we need to invest so we can offer our
customers more products
and technology
chips are scarce all over the world it's
a good time to invest
global foundries wants to double
production at its german site
nearby there's an infineon plant the
company is the global leader in the
production of vehicle chips
here too there are plans to expand
in the coming four to five years
infineon will invest a billion euros to
expand
this site the world's largest automotive
supplier bosch has also invested heavily
spending a billion euros on a new
factory
the region around the city of drayston
has become the hub of europe's
semiconductor industry
every second european chip is made here
we're the leading european region but
globally we still have a lot to do to
stay competitive
but the race is tough it's not over and
it's a global race
asia and the us are well ahead in this
race europe now wants to combine its
forces
to catch up and it's not only bosch
investing in this race but
also one of the world's leading chip
producers
uh joining me now is uh christine
eisenschmidt managing director vice
president of
intel germany good to have you with us
let's start first of all with a look at
the current
chip situation how much longer do you
think we will see shortages
yeah the global demand for cma
conductors today is higher than it has
ever been before
because we see the ongoing
digitalization that
is now impacting all areas of our daily
lives
whether it's schools whether it's
healthcare whether it's
cars so the demand for for powerful
chips is unprecedented
so we see that the um the shortage of
the chips will continue
and it will take a few years uh to be
resolved
right because building capacity is a
long-term game
and but building capacity that's also
something that intel is actually getting
into
already part of intel announced to
invest 20 billion dollars in the united
states
bosch as we've just said is just opening
its semiconductor factory in germany
when will intel follow suit here in
europe
well uh europe is a very very important
region for us and an important market we
are already invested in europe we've uh
invested
30 billion roughly in europe uh
over the last 30 years 22 billion in a
semiconductor manufacturing facility in
ireland which is state of the art
we are planning now a further expansion
to bring seven nanometer uh to the
region
which we are very proud of in addition
to that
we are planning to decide about a new uh
additional site in europe
uh and we are completely open to the
location at this point in time
but yes we are planning to expand and
invest in europe
you plan to invest in europe but you're
open to location and
time that somewhat sounds like this is
still
quite a while uh to go in the future i
mean how much money do you think and how
much
time is needed uh for the united states
and for europe to catch up with
asian chip producers also perhaps with
the investment help from intel
well first of all to build a new site a
new manufacturing facility takes usually
about four years at least now due to the
current shortage and the situation we
need to move faster and we need to speed
up
so we cannot do this alone so we
definitely need the help of
the eu of uh the local governments
in order to partner with us to make sure
that we can address the shortage and we
can
provide additional capacity as soon as
possible
so there you're talking about subsidies
is that is is
when you say you need the help of the eu
and partners we're talking about
subsidies
exactly for for other countries across
the globe
semiconductor manufacturing is a
national priority and we see them
investing heavily in in supporting
semiconductor manufacturers
in asia for example so in order to to
really achieve our european goals to
double the production in europe or over
the next
10 years until 2030 we think that a lot
of
investment and engagement from
government is is uh right
relevant and important to partner with
us to partner with the key semiconductor
manufacturers
now for a company like intel it's just
there's
one very important question that i need
to get out for a company like
intel uh do you think that what we see
right now is a kind of decoupling
from asia from the us and the european
side and if so is that desirable
well i think we've seen that we are
facing a shortage and right now we have
limited flexibility to react to these
circumstances
so being prepared to be more flexible
and to
to uh reduce our vulnerabilities and
dependencies
is definitely a key priority or a key
goal
so uh typically it's good to rely on
several pillars but but for sure
i think uh europe needs to become more
independent and
also combine design and manufacturing in
the region if we want to
to retain the flexibility and if we want
to come to a more balanced approach
we had intel we believe really in our in
a balanced approach
christine eisenschmidt their managing
director vice president of intel germany
thank you so much for your time
thank you it's a pleasure